en este vídeo les voy a enseñar una
nueva forma de hacer divisiones
especialmente para números largos y
vamos a pensar un poco en este ejemplo
que sigue vamos a tratar de calcular 96
entre 4 y lo voy a escribir un poco
diferente aquí escribo 96 y voy a poner
este símbolo raro aquí que cubre al 96 y
lo que esto significa es 96 dividido
entre 4 y en un momento van a ver por
qué lo escribe así esta es una forma muy
útil para calcular una división y aquí
decimos cuántas veces cabe el 4 en el 9
sabemos que 4 por 2 es igual a 8 y 4 por
3 es igual a 12 entonces 3 sería
demasiado grande se pasa del 9
necesitamos un número que sea menor que
9 tampoco mucho menor para que no nos
sobre demasiado
necesitamos un número más cercano al 9
pero que no sea mayor así que podemos
decir que dos veces el 4 cabe dos veces
en el 9 y cuánto es 4 por 2
bueno 4 por 2 es igual a 8 o 2 por 4 es
igual a 8 y ahora restamos le quitamos 8
al 9 y nos queda 19 8 es igual a 1 y
ahora bajamos el siguiente dígito que es
6 y preguntamos cuántas veces cabe el 4
en el 16 y en este caso sabemos que 4 x
4 es exactamente 16 así que 4x4 si
multiplicamos 4 x 4 es igual a 16 aquí
restamos 16 menos 16 es igual a cero y
aquí terminamos esto parece mágico pero
en un momento vamos a ver por qué
funciona bien vamos a pensar un poco
cómo es que funciona
vimos que 96 entre 4 es igual a 24 es
igual a 24 y lo que quiero que hagan en
este momento es pausar el vídeo y que
piensen porque funcionó cómo llegamos a
la respuesta correcta pueden verificarlo
multiplicando 4 por 24
y van a obtener 96 bueno asumo que le
hicieron hay algo que es muy importante
tener en mente siempre es el valor
posicional de los números que siempre
nos da una pista de lo que pasa en este
proceso cuando miramos a este 9 vemos
que está en la posición de las decenas y
que representa 90 representa 9 decenas
entonces lo que estamos diciendo en
realidad es cuántas veces cabe 4 en 90 y
si estamos pensando en múltiplos de 10
podemos decir entonces que cabe 20 veces
4 por 20 es igual a 80 y si decimos 4
por 20 es 80 nos quedan todavía 16 que
podemos dividir entre 4 y luego 4 cabe
cuatro veces en el 16 entonces primero
descubrimos que el 4 cabe 20 veces y no
llegamos a 96 así que con lo que queda
podemos repartir otros 4 espero que esto
haya servido